une scène inhabituelle dans les rues de
lyon des dizaines de tracteurs
d'agriculteurs ont investi la ville en
fin de matinée après une opération
escargot sur le réseau routier lyonnais
venus du rhône de l'ain et de la drôme
les véhicules avec des remorques
chargées de pneus et de fumier ont
encerclé la place bellecour
objectif de ces agriculteurs dénoncer
les promesses non tenues par emmanuel
macron est pointé du doigt
l'inefficacité de la loi y anime un
dispositif censé leur garantir une plus
juste rémunération
bien sûr content avec ma paire puisqu'on
a des revenus qui sont trop insuffisant
et qu'on peut considérer comme à perte
puisque on a beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui
sont entre à peine à 1000 euros de
revenus nets par mois c'est inadmissible
par rapport aux eur qu'on peut passer
jusqu'à un agriculteur fait à peu près
entre 60 et 70 heures par semaine
une action coup de poing qui s'est
déroulée sans débordement après avoir
été reçue à la préfecture du rhône
les agriculteurs ont annoncé l'obtention
d'un rendez vous avec le ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
julien de normandie la victoire se
concrétisera début de semaine derni
baylet quand on aura les annonces du
ministre mais les annonces concrètes et
pas des belles paroles et belles paroles
en aveugle nous faut aujourd'hui des
engagements écrits qui est se traduiront
par une modification de la loi et halim
le départ des protestataires a eu lieu
dans le calme comme le reste de la
journée mais les agriculteurs ont mis en
garde les autorités
si rien ne change d'ici les vacances de
pâques lyon sera de nouveau envahi par
les tracteurs et cette fois ci la
manifestation pourrait être bien plus
agité